11-year-old isim Dum a boy born with
hereditary deafness was the first to
receive the experimental treatment in
the United States doctors at the
Children's Hospital of Philadelphia
inserted a dose of gene therapy into his
inner ear and a month later he could
hear if you heard that told me yes
pretty cool his hearing is improved from
a a state of complete and profound
deafness with no sound at all to the
level of mild to mod hearing loss
researchers at Fudan University in China
and at Boston's massachusetts's Eye and
Ear have announced similarly promising
results their study published this week
in the Lancet medical journal documents
significantly restored Hearing in five
of six children treated in China
Mama M researchers say this child was
born with complete deafness 13 weeks
post surgery she can hear and respond to
her father's
voice but the studies have so far been
small and only one gene mutation out of
the dozens that can cause deafness has
been targeted one of the most important
aspect of the study really is to open up
a door to show this type of gene therapy
can work and for genetically hearing
loss there are also ethical
considerations Teresa Blan me Burke is a
bioethicist at gadet University who says
people with deafness can already
flourish we can see that be the case
here with many people in the world who
have had experiences of living good
lives happy lives and I would like to
see our science dollars
focused on those issues wherein there's
great suffering where people will die
early still researchers are excited the
studies will be presented at a meeting
of international hearing researchers in
California next month Heidi Joe Castro
Al jazer
Washington make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from
aljazera